I suppose last year when I was reviewing
the Metal Gear Solid games this would
have been an opportune time to review
peace Walker but I didn't the middle
you're still at 5 Ground zeroes is right
around the corner so should review peace
Walker
I know and the words a big boss kept you
waiting
[Music]
Metal Gear Solid Peace Walker so Metal
Gear Solid Peace Walker was actually a
PSP game which is really hard to control
in the PSP I played a few missions on
and I had to put it down I was like I
can't do that she moved with the one
analog thing that they give you on PSP
the analog slider he used two triangle
square circlex buttons to move the
camera around as if it was the second
analog I was just playing like luckily
the HD collection came out so you
actually control it like an actual
controller basically it's easier to
control on a ps3 controller so I was
right in it right spoiler alert there's
gonna be a lot of spoilers I'm gonna
talk about this game as if you have
played the game and in the plot a piece
Walker you play as big boss who left the
United States ten years prior in between
his portable ops but that wasn't a
kijima directed game so I was like is it
nothing in peace walker really alludes
to the fact that you need to play
portable of so I feel like you can skip
portable ops and go right into this if
you want to point is it's ten years
after the events of Snake Eater big boss
is like I'm done I don't even like the
title big boss he and Kaz Miller create
their army without a nation and they're
mercenaries these people from Costa Rica
are like people are invading our land
big boss is straight up like John Rambo
at this point you bring any weapons he's
a wanderer he's a drifter he's a nomad
but he's a badass so for the sake of
this girl Paz he's like I will liberate
your country also because there's this
audio tape where he hears the boss's
voice yeah the boss his mentor the one
he killed and Snake Eater so he's like I
need to find out what's going on so you
embark on this quest this quest that
ultimately is built for a portable
system the game is built on the fact
that you can wait in a line and be like
I want to crank out a couple missions to
its mission base it's built on the
system where you recruit guys in the
battlefield you can recruit bosses also
if you have the means tranq the boss
don't kill them cuz these dudes bring
some pretty badass stats to mother base
and based on their stats you allocate
them to different departments and the
mother base starts growing if you are d
department gives you attack and it gives
you weapons that's how you get better
weapons and in the end you look at this
thing you're like I have just created
outer heaven that's what I did I spent
like 36 hours in my first run-through in
this game because you're like I want to
do more missions these missions were
awesome at first I thought that would
detract oh my god missions I like a more
open world feeling even in Metal Gear
Solid 1 you can run from one end of
shadow Moses to the other ultimately and
this one's like this mission
consists of two or three zones and you
just go there and do your mission and
then you go back to mother base and now
you have these zones and you go there
and it's a little different but it
actually does work and peace Walker is a
nuclear deterrent because nuclear
deterrence works because the concept of
if I launch nukes at that country that
country is gonna launch nukes back and
it's a big hutton nuclear holocaust and
it sucks but people might not actually
push the button to retaliate back if
nukes are coming at them but peace
Walker is an AI system it calculates
like nope we need to because that's what
we need to do it goes in the concept
that humans are flawed so AI is a better
route you see that's what happened in
Metal Gear Solid 4 so it's cool seeing
that Prelude you're like oh people are
jumping on the AI train Iran that'll
lead to everything that's a shitstorm
that becomes Metal Gear Solid 4 in the
resolution couple things about this game
I am reserved about that I'm like I
don't quite buy that one the boss P in
the AI I don't like that I understand
they did it so snake and find resolution
with him killing the boss which for a
large section of this game I backed up
and I was like I thought he knew the
boss wasn't actually an that she
defected so she could do her mission and
snake had to kill her because that was
the mission people had to believe she
was a traitor but she actually wasn't
she was actually a pretty badass hero
she's like you know sniff and this one
snakes like what happened I don't know
what happened did she actually defect I
don't know I'm like didn't you get a
tape from Eva that told you the whole
story just I don't know when big boss is
walking out to the grave and he salutes
it and he cries you just get the feeling
that he knows that she's not a traitor
and she is a hero and it goes back to
well I don't really know that so it's
gonna confuse that he just completely
forgot about that by the end of the
game you have to jump to your own
conclusions ultimately but I kind of see
it as Eva was a spy she was a triple
agent so can he take her word for it
what's the tape a cover-up by the US
government was it all was it
the truth so snake or Big Boss he told
himself for enough years late now she's
defected because that's how I can
justify in my mind's eye killing her so
he ultimately wanted to believe that
most by the end of this game he's like
no she didn't she died because the times
killed her so that's all fine and dandy
but did you really have to have her AI
be a part of this game and by the end of
it you're fighting peace Walker which is
that's actually a badass scene I will
get down to the Peace Walker fight in a
second but you waste this piece Walker
and the thing is destroyed you pull out
all its AI cards and you Jack it up and
it's still alive and he's like I was
like the human
when there's a damaged part of the brain
another part of the brain will pick up
the slack and fill the role of that
damaged part that was like this biology
that's not machines it's completely
different if I pull out my graphics card
my RAM is not gonna become my graphics
card it just just doesn't have a
graphics card mat so I call on
that I'm like no that's just too sappy
for me it's just too ethereal in a
kind of way every Metal Gear
game has its weird element I guess this
is the line though that's where I draw
the line also the fact that you even
have Huey on your team I like Huey I
like any emmerich anything because
Howell emmerich was awesome Huey is just
like him but they don't buy the fact
that he'll Emmerich's dad happened to be
working with big boss just like Hal
Emmerich would randomly be working with
Solid Snake's let's to coincidental and
you can sailor who it was all meant to
be though the past echoes the future but
at a point you got to think alright is
it echoing or is it just kind of ripping
off your former ideas you would think in
Metal Gear Solid 1 when Hal Emmerich's
like my grandfather worked on the
Manhattan Project it's like nukes are in
our DNA he wouldn't drop the facts like
yeah and my dad worked with that big
boss cat oh you know who that is holy
that's nuts look at coincidence we
live in but I like Huey I just don't buy
the fact that he'd randomly come across
Big Boss this actually has a cool
element that a personals like I don't
like that I yeah I would like in the old
Metal Gear games you get any guns and
you just have those guns
I found 50,000 guns who somehow has them
all on him this game goes on the system
where it's like you have your suit your
suit can hold a couple guns a couple of
grenades some healing items some radars
and that's what you have so among the
whole arsenal you get you have to pick
which guns you like and I actually end
up liking that more cuz in the end if
you get 50,000 guns you're gonna use a
couple that fit you you don't need
50,000 guns you just need a few so I
actually like that I like the fact that
you have to pick and choose what you
want for your missions and you just go
from there and when you come behind
someone in headlock them I like the fact
that you can threaten them like start
talking and you can get information out
of them that's really awesome but I
don't like the fact that you can't drag
them one of the coolest things about
Metal Gear Solid 4 as long as Metal Gear
Solid has been Metal Gear Solid's when
you headlock someone you can drag them
behind something then break their neck
long to me out that you can't drag
people I mean you lay down on the ground
you just lay down you can't crawl and
we're talking this is a tactical
espionage operations game I think army
crawling would be a big part of that
no no army crawling you just lay down
like a slug like Randy and Christmas
story it's your only defense but I do
like the additions they did with CQC in
this one if you take someone down if
someone else is around you push r1 at
the right moment you'll take him down
you can keep
doing that you take out a few different
guys all than one CQC match it makes a
big boss feel more badass and it's more
realistic it's like the best soldier
that ever lived of course he'd be able
to take out multiple guys that I hope
they keep for the next game and the
cutscenes in this game take a little
getting used to all the other Metal Gear
Solid games have been in-game graphics
cinematic cutscenes makes it feel like a
movie but the graphics that you're used
to for gameplays so it engages you this
one is comic book animation style first
of all technologically I get why they
had to do it I guess the PSP couldn't
handle in-game cutscenes I get that
sometimes you're limited from the
technology that's available to you all
right it doesn't change the fact that it
is less engaging it's harder to get into
the story I would actually love to see a
patch where they patch this game and
give it in-game graphics for the HD
collection I understand why they're not
going to though because kind of
disrespectful to the person who did the
art course it'll be like dude what gives
what am I the Emperor and Empire Strikes
Back George Lucas you're gonna go ahead
and edit me out of the movie the awesome
fan tattoo
I love the peace walker battle here it
is you're fighting peace Walker and this
thing is gonna launch nukes and it's
just a nuclear holocaust is about to go
down and so the peace walker theme
starts kicking on but like in a really
jacked up kind of way the peace walker
soundtrack it's one of the best
soundtracks and all the Metal Gear Solid
games seriously
[Music]
so you're okay you're just shooting this
thing for all your work this things like
launch mode activate it has a countdown
timer you just have to shoot the sake
you're like you feel I swear you beat
this thing on your first try or you just
you're sad for seven days you failed not
just America but the world at this point
it's like that 13 days Cuban Missile
Crisis is going down everyone's
gonna launch their nukes so a whole
situation with peace Walker about the
launch that fired the dialogue it made
the game for me the fight with Metal
Gear Zeke maybe want to throw my
controller through my TV but the
peaceful Agra fight that was a lot of
fun think about pasta sauce is actually
a traitor and I loved that dialogue also
cuz she's like no people are actually
stupid you need to control the
battlefield with an AI that's smarter
than people so people go about their
lives never knowing they're being
controlled but they are controlled you
like Ursula and she's like I'm sick and
tired of a teen with the dream routine
I'm done with it they're like okay
you're not a teenager you actually do a
date with puss and Big Boss and heard
get under the cardboard box and just
bang the brains out big boss thought she
was yeah I was always under the
impression she was young like
the fact that she isn't doesn't change
the fact that Big Boss probably thought
she was too so Big Boss you may have
walked away from your country of origin
but nothing is more America than that my
friend India and Metal Gear Solid Peace
walkers really fun game it plays the
best on a portable system like the Vita
get a Vita so you can have like two
danielaube controllers it's a really fun
console based game also just sitting on
your couch but you can tell it is made
to be portable couple of the combat
mechanics I hope they tweak for ground
zeroes and phantom pain I want to be
able to drag people want to be able to
do more and I think you can from based
on the footage I've seen and there are a
couple of story based things from look I
don't buy that it's way too convenient
among the gameplay aspects I didn't
enjoy as much there were other gameplay
aspects that I really enjoyed that
counter balance did likewise of the
story based elements that I call
on there were story based
elements where I was like that is
awesome you can't deny that India
and Metal Gear Solid Peace Walker is
worth buying at full price it is my
least favorite of the Metal Gear Solid
games but it is a sweet-ass game and it
sets the stage for something that's
gonna be really sweet there's a metal
gear solid piece Walker have you played
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]